it's doubtful if you really understand
something if you can't explain why it's
true and that's what proofs are about in
mathematics and in computer science so
we're going to be talking about proofs
of lots of things that we're trying to
understand and in particular we're going
to look at a proof technique now called
proof by contradiction which is probably
so familiar that you never noticed you
were using it and now we're going to
call explicit - attention to it and
think about it so let's do an example
first to see what's going on suppose
that I wanted to prove that the cube
root of 1332 was less than or equal to
11 or more precisely suppose I didn't
know and I'm asking this question is the
cube root of 1332 less than or equal to
11 well one way to do it would be to
simply compute the cube root of 1332
which is a small bother but manageable
but there's a simpler way that figuring
out how to compute a square root of a
4-digit a cube root of a four-digit
number let's just suppose that this
inequality was true that is that the
cube root of 1332 was less than or equal
to 11 well if that was true then what I
could do is cube both sides and I'll
conclude that 1332 is less than equal to
11 cubed now 11 cubed is a lot easier to
compute than the cube root of 1332 as a
matter of fact 11 cubed is 1331 wait a
minute
I've just concluded that 1332 is less
than 1331 that's obviously not true
which means that my assumption that this
inequality held doesn't make sense it
leads to this immediate contradiction
which means that in fact the inequality
doesn't hold and I have now precisely
and unambiguously I hope clearly proved
that the cube root of 1332 is greater
than 11 even though we never actually
computed the cube root of 1332 oh this
is kind of a
toy and simple-minded example to
illustrate proof by contradiction so
let's step back and explain and say what
it is in general if an assertion implies
something false then the assertion
itself must be false that's what's going
on here if your reasoning step by step
and in every step your reason your
reasoning is good which means that if
you had something true and then you
reach the conclusion from it in one step
the conclusion that you reached was also
true then if you start off with some
assumption and you keep proving things
step by step in a way that preserves
truth and you arrive at something false
it's inevitable that what you started
with must have been false or else the
thing you finished with would have been
true ok let's look at a real example of
this an amazing fact that was known
thousands of years ago to the ancient
Greeks which is that the square root of
2 is irrational now let's remember that
a rational number is a fraction a
rational number is a quotient of
integers and the way we're going to
prove that the square root of 2 is not a
quotient of integers is by assuming that
it was so let's assume that the square
root of 2 was a rational number which
means that we've got integers N and D
without common prime factors such that
the square root of 2 is equal to n over
D what I'm doing here is I'm saying the
square root of 2 is a fraction and over
D and we know that you can always reduce
a fraction to lowest terms which means
there is no common factor so let's get
that done we have the square root of 2
is equal to n over D with no prime that
divides both N and D from this
assumption I'm going to prove to you
that both N and D are even and that of
course is an immediate contradiction
because then both N and they have a
common factor too so all I got to do in
order to conclude that the square root
of 2 is an irrational number it's not a
fraction is prove to you that N and D
are both even if the square root of 2 is
equal to n over D well let's do that
we'll start off with
what I'm assuming square root of two is
n over D and let's get rid of the
denominator so let's multiply through
both sides by day and get that the
square root of two times D is equal to n
let's get rid of the square root of two
now by squaring both sides and I get to
D squared is N squared well that's great
because look the left-hand side is
divisible by two there it is which means
that N squared is divisible by two the
right-hand side is even but if N squared
is even then n is even and I'm halfway
there I've shown that the numerator is
even okay let's keep going now this is n
is even it was equal to twice something
so n is two K for some number K I don't
care what K is let's square both sides
of that and conclude that N squared is
equal to 4 K squared why did I square it
so that I could connect up here with the
equation the other equation that I had
about N squared that N squared was 2d
squared so combining these two what I
get is the 2d sword is equal to 4 K
squared and of course I can cancel two
and get the d squared is equal to 2k
squared and again I've got the right
hand side is divisible by 2 so the left
hand side is divisible by 2 these
squared is even and therefore T is even
and we've completed the proof as claimed
and and they both have to is a common
factor contradicting the fact that
they're in lowest terms now I did assume
something that is kind of obvious namely
that if N squared is even then n is even
why is this true well you might think
about it for a moment there's a simple
way to see it and it's approved by
contradiction we're going to use a fact
that you can verify easily enough by
doing a little arithmetic namely the
product of two odd numbers is odd what's
assumed 1 so if the product of two odd
numbers is odd if I tell you that N
squared is even and suppose that n was
not even well that means it's odd but
that would mean that N squared was odd
contradicting the fact that n is even
therefore also contradiction to assume
that n is odd must be even
that's a ad hoc proof that has to do
with even listen oddness there's a more
general way to understand this that
actually will come in handy on namely
that what I know is that numbers factor
into primes in a unique way so if I tell
you that N squared is even what I know
about N squared is that all the primes
that divide N squared
come from n so if there's a two among
the primes that divide N squared it has
to be a two that is one of the prime
divisors of N and that would work even
if we what if I told you that N squared
was divisible by three it would follow
by that reasoning that n is divisible by
three now that's a powerful fact I'm
assuming the prime factorization of
integers and it's not obvious at all
that that's true although it's very
familiar it's okay to assume in a few
weeks we'll actually look back at how to
carefully prove that but for now it's
okay to assume and we also have the
simple argument that work at the based
on properties of even and odd that if N
squared is even and n is even that's the
last gap in the proof and so we're done